[Music]
you recently got married this is very
exciting recently got married in
Colorado at the Stanley Hotel in Estes
Park where Stephen King's got inspired
to write the shining you went to the
hotel that inspired the shining you get
married ha ha was it creepy and spooky
it must be well I wanted it to be more
creepy and spooky because I thought you
know if ghosts come out and bug my
guests that's entertainment that I don't
have to pay for the ghost hunters
they've done like two episodes there
when I talked to a woman who worked at
the spa they're like yeah they just come
and get massages all day and just wait
for a ghost to wait for a ghost where
you get a massage all right traditional
wedding what kind of wedding we talking
about here I'm gonna guess a little less
than traditional well it's a bit quirky
we did have two llamas in our bridal
party one had a bow tie on the groom's
side and then we had one flowers on on
my side why did you have llamas I think
they're good luck for weddings never
heard that before
did you just think that you hear
somewhere they're good lucky you just
saw let's have llamas well like my
husband loves llamas he thinks they're
hilarious and if you look at their face
up close when they smile I think they're
so funny though we had and and Kurt
Braunohler he was my maid of honor and
and he's his llama kept circling around
him and fidgeting like through the whole
ceremony sit still yeah and I missed
half of it like I didn't realize we said
I do cuz I got so distracted and it
turns out that afterwards after the
ceremony the llama walked back around
outside to the grass and just pissed for
10 solid minutes
I decided to go to the bathroom that
whole time but it was a trained llama so
it knew that it shouldn't relieve itself
in front of an audience which is one of
the first lessons of performing that's
fantastic no one told Carl Reiner